okay we were solving trigonometric
equations last time and we looked at
this as an example question I think one
of the ideas that we got across was that
after you go from here to here using
what we know about treating expansions
so there's actually a fair bit of
working in there what you've turned your
question into is just a regular old
trigonometric equation that has nothing
to do with expansions okay so in a sense
what we're doing is we're using
expansions to bring up questions like
this which were more complex to ones
that we knew how to solve before okay
but there's still lots of little traps
to fall into after you get through that
point so let's pick up where we left off
we got into a factorize point and we
looked at the two factors and solved
each one fit there being equal to zero
okay so here's 10x equals y and you can
solve that with your graph or by
remembering the exact mode when you get
across to here because that you've got
is a 10 square and not 10x it's me have
to be very cautious that you remember
when you take the square root of both
sides right yes
it's not just equal to 102 because you
could take negative root 2 negative 1
over root 2 you can also square that and
it worked for the previous line so plus
or minus okay
now you may think that's extra work for
you to do because there's gonna be twice
as many solutions but actually it
simplifies the approach you have to take
when you're trying to work out what the
right angles are okay so plus or minus
means when you think about your 4
quadrants these four quadrants tell you
where each function is positive or
negative right so when I've got plus or
minus that means I don't have to worry
about which quadrant I'm in I'm actually
in the positive quadrant and the
negative quadrants this is for tan right
so I just take every quadrant now I'm
going to get four angles so what you'll
need is at this point to get your
calculator out
because it's just not the exact value
and when you punch in 10 inverse of just
regular Lord 1 over 2
okay what the calculator will tell you
because when you think about what Ted or
really um really way any trigonometric
graph looks like you're getting an
infinite number of solutions right so I
could pick this one or this one or this
one
I want a few of these yeah but the
calculator will just tell you the first
one that it can find they haven't got
one closest to the artist sometimes
it'll go negative as well so in this
case the angle gives you is 35 degrees
and some number of minutes okay now
usually you'd be expected to give it two
minutes accuracy which is which would be
16 minutes when you do the calculation
but just for the simplicity of this
question and just to illustrate the
process rather than focus on the
precision of the answer I'll just leave
is 35 degrees that's to the course just
degree now 35 degrees that's what you
might call your base angle okay it's
your angle in the first quadrant 35
degrees okay so how do you use that
angle to work out what the other three
angles will be to get your four
solutions well when you go to the second
quadrant okay your answer is gonna take
the fall if I call this base angle theta
okay in the second quadrant you're going
to be finding 180 degrees minus theta
okay so that's this angle here and if
I've got my - 35 yeah so the actual
angle I want is all the way from 0 up to
145 okay so there's my second angle to
get my angle in a third quadrant I don't
go 180 minus theta I go 180 plus okay so
there it goes again this another 35
degrees so the actual angle that I want
the whole angle is going to be 215
that's what this reflex angle in here is
and when I go into my final quadrant the
fourth line again I've got to get
another reflex angle this time like this
it would be 180 minus there will be 360
- okay so here's our last angle that's
35 in there so the actual angle and
after whoops all the way around to here
so it's 325 all right so there's my four
angles that I'm after 35 degree D is 145
to 15 and 325 okay so I've got four
solutions from this side of the or this
factor of the equation
I got three from over here so to tie it
all up I need to write or seven down now
to be least it'll probably be nice to
put all seven down in ascending order or
at least this some order but you know
when you're gonna heart rate if you're
the exam that kind of thing it's fine
just to write these three down and
they're right
and there's your there's your solution
so I think the important things to watch
out for in this question because we just
had we had all four quadrants so in
substances I didn't need to be
discerning about which quadrant I was
feeding I'll stick you all of them so if
you are something different over here
suppose on one of your branches instead
of 1 minus 2 10 squared X right it was
just 1 minus 2 just 1/10 it okay when
I'm solving this I've got 10 X is equal
to 1/2 so seeing is 10 is positive ok
again when you come back to your diagram
you just got to remember you have to
disregard some of the quadrants right so
tangent is positive so first quadrant
and third quadrant will be where my
answers are okay so watch out for that
and then once you've got all of your
answers you can conclude the off
available place okay